nosotros ya sabemos cómo nombrar al
canon por ejemplo con este alcano de acá
sabemos que tiene 5 carbonos y no tiene
ningún enlace doble por lo que sabemos
que se llama pantano pero cómo le
hacemos si lo que queremos nombrar es un
al que no aunque hay por aquí esta
molécula tiene un doble enlace pero
también tiene 5 carbonos 1 2 3 4 y 5
bueno pues empezamos con pent indicando
que tenemos 5 carbonos en esta molécula
pero como tenemos un doble enlace vamos
a cambiar la terminación de a n
e n a esta molécula se llama centeno y
queremos numerar estos carbonos de tal
forma que el enlace doble tenga el menor
número posible así es que vamos a
empezar desde la izquierda
este es el carbono 1 este es el 2 3
4 y 5 por lo que este enlace doble se
encuentra en el carbono 1 y ponemos por
aquí 1 centeno
si el enlace doble se encuentra en el
carbono número 1 podemos omitir esta
parte porque siempre que no pongamos el
número en el que se encuentra el enlace
doble estamos suponiendo que se
encuentra en el carbono 1 bueno pero qué
pasa si se nos ocurre numerar a esta
molécula empezando por el carbono de la
derecha qué pasa si decimos que este es
el carbono 1 este es el 2 3 4 y 5 en
este caso el enlace doble empieza en el
carbono 4 y entonces diríamos que esta
molécula es un 4 centeno pero esta forma
de hacer las cosas está muy mal porque
queremos darle al enlace doble el menor
número posible y eso se logra enumerando
los carbonos de esta forma esta molécula
se llama 1 centeno o también podemos
omitir el 1 y llamarle simplemente p
ahora vamos a ponerle nombre a esta
molécula así es que queremos buscar la
cadena de carbonos más larga que
contenga al doble enlace y también
queremos ponerle los números más
pequeños a los carbonos de este doble
enlace entonces para cumplir esas dos
condiciones este tiene que ser el
carbono 1 este el carbono 2 este el 3 el
4 y el 5 tenemos aquí una cadena de 5
carbonos con doble enlace estamos
hablando de un puente no y como el
enlace doble empieza en el carbono 1
podemos poner aquí el 1 o simplemente
dejarlo así y a continuación tenemos que
pensar en los sustituye entes pero en
este caso tenemos sólo un sustituye ente
enlazado con nuestra cadena de carbonos
y es un grupo al kilo de dos carbonos a
éstos les llamamos grupos estilos a esta
molécula con un grupo de tilos en el
carbono 2 le llamamos
útil centeno bueno pero podría ser que
alguien llegue y diga oye esta no es la
cadena de carbonos más larga de esta
molécula no debería ser este el carbono
1 este el carbono 2 este el 3 el 4 el 5
y el 6 porque hay aquí tenemos una
cadena de 6 carbonos y por acá
únicamente tenemos 5 pero no podemos
hacerlo así porque el doble enlace tiene
que ser parte de la cadena de carbonos y
esa es una de las reglas tenemos que
buscar la cadena de carbonos más larga
que contenga al doble enlace por eso es
que esta molécula es un puente no y por
eso no lo numerados de esta otra forma
esta forma es incorrecta tenemos que
buscar la cadena de carbonos más larga
que contenga el enlace doble y además
hacer esta numeración de tal forma que
el enlace doble reciba la menor
numeración posible y es
pasa incluso si tenemos algunos otros
grupos sustituyen test por ejemplo ahora
vamos a ponerle el nombre a esta
molécula primero vamos a enumerar los
carbonos de esta cadena de izquierda a
derecha
este es el carbono 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 y un el
que no de 6 carbonos es un externo y su
enlace doble lo tenemos por acá está en
el carbono 2 ok entonces este es un 2
externo bueno y ahora vamos a pensar en
todos estos sustituye entes de esta
cadena de carbonos incluyendo al doble
enlace tenemos un grupo metilo en el
carbono 2 otro grupo metilo en el
carbono 4 y un último grupo metilo en el
carbono 5 entonces como tenemos tres
grupos metilo tenemos que poner aquí
three metil porque son tres grupos
metilo que están en el carbono 2 4 y 5
es 1 2
2 532 exc no ahora hay otra forma de
llamarle a esta molécula y es tomar este
2 y ponerlo en medio del ex y el heno
seguimos teniendo esta parte de los tres
grupos metidos 2 453 metil pero ahora
ponemos primero -ex luego la
localización del doble enlace o sea que
ponemos por aquí 1 2 y terminamos con la
terminación en no esta parte de aquí nos
está indicando que el doble enlace se
encuentra en el carbono 2 la primera
forma que utilizamos para nombrar esta
molécula podríamos decir que es la forma
más antigua de llamarle y el segundo
nombre que escribimos es la forma más
reciente pero por el momento la mayoría
de las personas aceptarían cualquiera de
estas dos formas bueno pero ahora vamos
a ver qué pasa si numerados a esta
cadena de carbonos de derecha a
izquierda aunque hay digamos que este es
el carbono 1
2 3 4 5 y 6 podría ser que tú llegara si
dijeras oye esta es la forma en la que
tenemos que enumerar a estos carbonos
porque de esta forma tenemos grupos
metidos en los carbonos 2 3 y 5 okay
tenemos grupos metidos en los carbonos 2
3 y 5 y si comparamos estas numeraciones
los dos los tenemos en un 2 pero el
segundo grupo metilo con esta nueva
inglaterra tenemos un 4 y con esta
tenemos un 3 y claro siempre preferimos
que tengan el menor número posible
entonces podríamos pensar que estos
grupos al kilos nos están indicando que
tenemos que enumerar de derecha a
izquierda
el problema con esta nomenclatura es que
entonces el doble enlace se encuentra en
el carbono 4 y nuestro objetivo
principal es darle al enlace doble el
menor número posible preferimos darle el
menor número posible al doble enlace
y que darle menores números a los grupos
al kilos el doble enlace tiene prioridad
entonces tenemos que enumerar a estos
carbonos de esta forma 245 three metil 2
externo es el nombre correcto de este
compuesto según la nomenclatura iupac
pero bueno ahora vamos a ver ejemplos
con ciclos por aquí a la izquierda ya
sabemos que éste se llama ciclohexano
con una terminación a n o sea esta
molécula le ponemos un enlace doble
entonces ahora se llama ciclo externo
con una terminación n
ahora para numerar a los carbonos
cualquiera de estos dos carbonos podría
ser el carbono 1 entonces vamos a
empezar diciendo que este es el carbono
1 pero si éste es el carbono 1 entonces
éste tiene que ser el carbono 2
este es el 3 4 5 y 6 y para qué nos
sirve enumerar los bueno pues porque
podemos tener sustituye entes y
ahora vamos a ver ejemplos de ciclo
externos con algunos sustituye entes
vamos a empezar por acá queremos darle a
nuestro sustituye ente el menor número
posible también sabemos que tenemos que
empezar la numeración en alguno de los
carbonos del doble enlace entonces o
este carbono es el 1 o este carbono es
el 10 para hacer que el grupo sustituye
ente tenga el menor número posible vamos
a hacer que este carbono sea el 1 y
entonces este carbono tiene que ser el 2
y así se sigue la numeración ok entonces
aquí tenemos un ciclo externo y aquí en
el carbono número 1 tenemos un grupo
metilo entonces tenemos que agregar 1
metilo y la nomenclatura para esta
molécula es 1 metil ciclo externo pero
bueno ahora vamos a ponerle el nombre a
esta molécula otra vez tenemos un ciclo
con 6 carbonos y un enlace doble por lo
que se trata de un ciclo externo
tenemos aquí una elección o puede ser
este el carbono 1
este es el carbono 1 pero si hacemos que
este sea el carbono 1 entonces este
grupo sustituye ente tiene un menor
número así es que si vamos a hacer que
éste sea el carbono 1 y para seguir con
la numeración tenemos que ir en la
dirección del doble enlace ok
este tiene que ser el carbono 2 y por lo
tanto éste tiene que ser el carbono 3 y
ahora sí ya estamos listos para agregar
el nombre de estos grupos sustituye
entes lo que hay aquí en el carbono 3
tenemos dos grupos metilo a eso le
llamamos dimetil pero ambos están en el
carbono 3
entonces le ponemos 3 3 dimetil ciclo
externo y además por acá en el carbono 1
tenemos un grupo estilo así es que
ponemos 1 steel 33 dimetil ciclo externo
y ahora porque utilizamos este orden
bueno pues estamos
el orden alfabético porque la inicial
del grupo de tilo va antes que la
inicial del grupo metilo y listo el
nombre de esta molécula es uno útil 33
dimetil ciclo externo